hi i'm annie onishi and i'm a trauma
surgeon
and this is each and every injury in
home alone
[Music]
we're gonna be talking about all of the
injuries from home alone parts one and
two three and four we don't have time
for that
[Music]
this is it don't get scared now
that first fall looks like the most
severe in this series he's up a couple
of steps he gets full air and then he
lands flat on his back that's going to
be a lot of force right on that landing
surface so harry's second fall doesn't
look as severe or dramatic as his first
but it is in the context of having
already had a great big fall and a great
big impact so if his ribs weren't broken
before i bet you they're broken now when
our ribs break the little edges can sort
of dislodge and damage internal organs
so from the back they can ding a kidney
they can ding a liver they can dig a
spleen
so my guess is a bunch of broken ribs
plus or minus hemo pneumothorax plus or
minus splenic lack marv falls down a
bunch of stairs but he sort of is at a
ground level when he does it and sort of
seems like a little bit less velocity
and force so i do think marv is a little
younger which may explain why he's able
to bounce back from this injury a little
faster
so looking straight up and having the
iron land on his face what that's gonna
do is what's called an axial loading
injury so there's a bunch of load
compressing the spine from top to bottom
this is most commonly seen in the
context of a young usually intoxicated
person jumping off of a bridge or the
edge of a pool into a shallow pool of
water and their head strikes the bottom
of either the lake or the pond or the
pool we have a ground level fall with a
head strike on the back what we worry
about from these ground level falls is
something called a coup contra coup
injury so we strike the back of our head
yeah our brain gets rocked from there
but then as the brain settles down
because it sits in a cavity of fluid it
hits the front of the skull as well so
you may expect to see some bleeding in
the back of the brain accompanied by
some bleeding in the front of the brain
as the brain sort of rocks about the
skull cavity itself
[Music]
we know that harry and marv are in for a
whole world of suffering tonight can see
how sensitive they seem to be to what is
probably more of a sensation of sort of
like a bee sting it could cause some
damage if it hit you right in the
eyeball if it was really close range
like that but in general every pellet
injury i've ever seen has just been in
the fat
[Music]
if i had to guess what type of burn this
is going to be my guess is going to be a
second degree which is a partial
thickness burn so it burns off the
epidermis part of the dermis which is
the deeper layer of skin the important
difference between second-degree burns
and third-degree burns is that with the
second degree burns you don't lose the
little stem cells that live in those
layers of skin so it will heal without a
scar so while he's branded with the
mcallister m now that's not going to be
permanent i would consider a burn what's
called a distracting injury so because
the burn hurts so bad and is so dramatic
and the patient is so worried about it
they may not have noticed that they fell
down a few stairs
[Music]
so marv has lost his socks lost his
shoes he is stepping on this nail here
it looks like it goes in about an inch
or two puncture injuries are notoriously
high risk for infection this tiny little
deep hole
that is dark and warm and full of blood
and is a great place for bacteria to
grow
[Music]
you can tell he's gotten good first aid
training because he dunks his head in
the snow it's probably mostly steam
coming off his head you can see that
he's lost a bunch of his hair and then
the skin doesn't have that pink
appearance that his hand had so probably
not as deep of a burn but still
definitely very painful you know i think
at this point um harry and marv really
should be suspicious that they are
invading the house of some sort of
psychopath
with like some very sadistic tendencies
and i would have turned away at this
point already
[Music]
my concern is that with glue on this
fresh burn on his head and then feathers
on his on the burn
i think that's gonna make wound care
really difficult so
some poor
burn nurse is gonna have to go through
and pick out every last little bit of
feather from that burn and that surface
area of that burn is way too big to numb
up well so he would just have to sort of
sit there as they picked out little bits
of feather from his burn skin i think
that's really gonna hurt
having abandoned entering the house
through any particular door because of
all the booby traps here we have marv
sneaking through a window and
encountering a bunch of christmas
ornaments that very fine glass that you
see that the ornaments are made of when
that shatters it splinters
and those little fine bits of glass are
impossible to get out it leads to a lot
of pain a lot of torture for both the
patient and whoever's trying to pick out
all that glass
i'm gonna kill that dead well the
patient's gonna go home with the
sensation of glass in his feet and he's
just gonna have to continue to keep his
feet soaked and this stuff will work its
way out eventually
maybe these guys should get their eyes
checked because the ground in front of
you should always be within your field
of view so for them to not have seen
those cars makes me a little concerned
that maybe from all these head injuries
they may have some sort of visual defect
no way to really know without further
testing but definitely makes me a little
suspicious
[Music]
when the neck hyperextends like that at
a fast rate with a lot of acceleration
and deceleration you can get something
called the hangman's fracture which is
when the second cervical vertebrae
breaks in a couple of places it's a
really unstable fracture it can be a
very high risk for a devastating cord
injury at that level the lay term for
these hyperextension type injuries is
whiplash whiplash really refers to all
the muscular stiffness you get after a
big hyper extension injury like that so
now we have a couple of other injuries
in rapid sequence so not only do we have
this hyperextension injury of the neck
then we have a heavy object in the form
of harry landing on marv
so if marv's ribs weren't broken before
my bet is they're going to be broken now
this little sequence
at a very minimum we have at least soft
tissue damage from a whiplash injury at
the worst we have something like a
hangman's fracture a hyperextension
injury of the neck
we have then a fall from height we have
a head strike and then we have crushed
by a heavy falling object
[Music]
that wire is very thick and very obvious
so they couldn't see it again i'm really
worried about their visual fields
they're just looks like they're not able
to see anything below about nose level
it's very concerning
a crowbar is going to cause a lot of
damage because that's that's just a
heavy metal object with a lot of
directed force at one particular
location it's kind of hard to see
exactly where this blow lands but it
looks sort of epigastrium which is the
sort of upper part of the central
abdomen to maybe some ribs or sternal
area this assault with the crowbar right
in this area to me is very reminiscent
of something we call a handlebar injury
so when somebody is riding their bike
and they crash and their handlebars jam
into their epigastric area and squishes
all the organs and and bruises them
lacerates them
so that can really cause a lot of damage
whenever our bodies decelerate in such a
fashion be it in a car on a bicycle
motorcycle or swinging from a rope
directly into a brick wall all of our
organs continue moving until they hit
the brick wall and they stop that's
called a deceleration injury a lot of
our organs including our heart our aorta
our small intestine our colon they're
tethered to the body wall in certain
locations so when we decelerate things
tear about that tether these
deceleration injuries can be really
subtle you can't necessarily see them on
a cat scan unless you're a special type
of cat scan or unless you have a very
high suspicion for such a thing
[Music]
as bleeding in the skull accumulates and
pushes on the brain and the brain swells
there's nowhere for the brain to go
because the skull is a fixed compact
cavity so when the brain continues to
swell the only place for it to go is
down and out which is called a
herniation so after this assault with
the shovel we see both guys completely
passed out total loss of consciousness
but then a couple minutes later these
guys are back up walking and talking
this makes me really concerned for
something called an epidural hematoma
what that means is that there's blood
accumulating in the epidural space which
is underneath the skull but outside the
brain and expanding slowly classically
these people have a big head bonk maybe
from a shovel they come to and then they
have what's called a lucid interval but
slowly but surely as that blood expands
within the epidural space they then
start to lose consciousness again and
can even go on to herniate and die
pretty quickly so this is actually a
story we get all the time especially
from the ski hill or after a bar fight
and everybody's like okay he's okay he's
gonna walk it off and then five ten
minutes later they've lost consciousness
again
so we just saw each and every injury in
home alone one either these guys are
really tough or they've got a great
trauma doctor because they're gonna be
back for home alone too
[Music]
[Applause]
well hello
did it
did what
lesson number one is don't mess with new
yorkers because that's what's going to
happen to you but with a good solid
right hook like that typically the point
of impact is the cheekbone here this is
something called the zygomatic arch this
is a relatively fragile bone as far as
facial structures go this is often the
first thing to break when somebody gets
hit especially when their face is
turning it looks like a pretty solid
punch but i think knowing these guys i
think they'll recover
well it looks like harry suffers a
pretty decent fall from height and
absolutely crushes this car kerry is
rendered speechless by this fall that's
either just the wind getting knocked out
of him is sort of the lay term
he may have broken a couple of ribs and
maybe
gotten what's called the pneumothorax
which is when the lungs collapse and air
is building up inside the thoracic
cavity but outside the lungs that could
make it pretty difficult to speak or to
get words out
i think out of all the injuries that we
will review today this series of
injuries is probably one of the more
severe ones it's probably a tie between
four bricks to the head from a high
height versus the shovel to the head by
the neighbor so his inability to speak
could be the sign of a pretty severe
brain bleed inside especially over the
area that controls our speech which is
usually the left side of our brain sort
of depends on the patient
[Music]
definitely at this point marv would need
to be rushed over to the hospital to get
checked out for his head trauma
[Music]
oh a nail gun to the buttock or the face
the er doc could just pull that out and
there's nothing majorly critical in
those areas the nail straight to the
groin the thing i would be concerned
about is an underlying vascular injury
such as to the femoral vein or the
femoral artery if there was an expanding
hematoma which means blood pulling up
underneath the nail that would be a
reason to go to the operating room to do
a nice cut down get all the vasculature
exposed and remove that nail under
really controlled circumstances
every fall from height is a little bit
different the injury pattern is pretty
recognizable so depending on whether
your ribs are broken whether your back
is broken whether you have any other
orthopedic injuries to your either your
pelvis your extremities solid organ
injuries like lacerating your spleen or
your liver from your fall that's going
to determine what needs to be done for
you in the hospital and what long-term
consequences you could expect with rib
fractures those people are in a pretty
real amount of pain for
four to six to eight weeks but certainly
a bad accident or a bad fall from height
can lead to lots of problems with
chronic pain in the future
here marv is falling straight from the
first floor that's a pretty decent
height and he falls flat on his front
and his face that is a pretty bad way to
land all of our bony structures at that
moment of impact are going to compress
and thereby squish all of our organs
inside so in addition to breaking stuff
like his sternum the fronts of his ribs
potentially his arms any fall from
height no matter how you land you're
probably gonna mess some stuff up
we suffer brain injuries more when the
brain is rocked within the fixed cavity
of the skull than really from just
direct blows this pile of tools landing
on him where things are just falling
from the top down and just compressing
the skull on top of the neck and the
spines definitely would expect some
brain trauma with this potentially some
neck trauma it looks like they also hit
sort of the shoulder and the arms and
some other things so we would really
have to check this guy carefully for
other orthopedic injuries
this is really reminding me of a
phenomenon that we have here in central
oregon called black ice that happens
overnight when just the water vapor from
the air just freezes right on the cement
and makes this tiny imperceptible layer
of ice so from the months of about
october to january we get tons and tons
of patients just like marv who are
slipping and sliding on the way out to
the car trying to catch their balance
and off they go
super common to see broken arms broken
wrists broken ribs from just a big fall
and some cement another injury that we
see here which is a really feared injury
is something called a straddle injury so
as marv is sliding towards this
bookshelf we can see him run into this
post between his legs at a decent amount
of velocity be it a motorcycle a bicycle
commonly a fence post as someone is
hopping a fence gets jammed up between
the legs and it's obviously a very
unpleasant series of injuries that can
lead to urogenital trauma that can lead
to rectal trauma it can lead to
hematomas in places where you really
don't want hematomas and they can be
really hard to deal with and very
difficult to control
i know i keep saying this but actually i
think this is the most lethal mechanism
we have seen yet to date this is a high
voltage electrical injury as the current
travels through the body the body
tissues act as a resistor which produces
heat as electricity travels through so
pretty much anything in the line of fire
from that source to where the patient's
grounded is just going to get fried the
most dangerous things that can happen
are cardiac arrhythmias so the heart is
an electrified organ so a big
dose of electricity is going to send the
heart into all kinds of crazy rhythms it
can cause kidney failure it can cause
the muscle tissue anywhere in the body
basically just to melt and liquefy which
leads to something called rhabdomyolysis
and it can lead to something called
compartment syndrome so as all the
tissues in the body are damaged and they
start leaking water they swell i think
kevin mcallister needs some help
this is an explosion and a fire within a
closed space of a toilet and a small
bathroom inhalational injury is what
happens when a patient suffers a burn in
a closed space so most commonly within a
car fire
the airway is subject to superheated air
and other
chemicals that are burning what that
leads to is severe swelling of the
airway to the point that the airway can
actually swell shut that's going to be a
giant heat sink with a lot of mechanical
force from the explosion directly to the
face and airways i probably think that
this is gonna be a non-survivable injury
but maybe i'll be proven wrong
my main piece of advice to these guys
would be to stop pulling on strings and
ropes in this house because only bad
things happen when they do that
[Music]
this is one construction accident i've
seen many times my number one
recommendation is you should always have
a buddy when you're using a ladder even
if you think it's simple even if you
think it's safe just have somebody down
at the bottom stabilizing things i mean
harry has marv marv has harry that's the
beauty of their relationship he looks to
be about five six feet off the ground
and hits his head is definitely gonna
rock with that impact definitely a high
risk for a concussion here
[Music]
i'm really really shocked and amazed by
marvin harry home alone part two this
house of horrors is way more dangerous
than the house back in chicago i think
these injuries look a lot more serious
but despite all that they've just really
done a great job of getting themselves
up dusting themselves off and continuing
on
so quick little anatomy lesson about the
nose so most of the nose that you can
feel is actually made of soft squishy
cartilage so it's not likely to break or
deform in any way so typically if
patients have broken a nose it doesn't
look squished in the front like what
these two guys have what it looks like
is either flattened to one side or if
it's been broken in this way it looks
flattened but only really between the
eyes and then really really swollen
accompanied by a couple of black eyes
too
[Music]
in medicine and in surgery we talk about
something called the ld50 which means
the lethal dose of something at which 50
of people when exposed will die the ld50
for a fall from height is largely
largely accepted as four stories so
anybody who falls four stories or more
has more than 50 chance of death i think
this particular incident is especially
dangerous for harry who falls from what
i would consider a lethal height
then his friend lands on top of him then
a bunch of paint cans fall from even
higher and land on top of him too so
those are three pretty dangerous
mechanisms all at once
i think the actual pecking itself is not
likely to be that dangerous however if
you spend a large amount of time in very
close proximity to pigeons they carry a
number of zoonotic diseases zoonotic
means a disease that you can catch from
an animal
that can be pretty dangerous to humans
there's a couple different types of
pneumonia you can pick up from a pigeon
namely something called histoplasmosis
all my friends living in new york if you
see a pigeon nesting on your windowsill
you should try to get rid of them
because they have these little mites and
they can apparently crawl through your
window and infest your bed and then
infest you
[Music]
there you have it that was each and
every injury in home alone